Harvard has a long tradition of service
to all of our neighbors both near and far
and it has been a key part of the university since
its founding.
service is a core aspect of all we do at Harvard.
Service in terms of what we discover
and the ways it can change the world, service
in the form of
teaching and communicating knowledge, but also service
in the way
in which we relate to our communities both
local,
national and global.
Service experience gives Harvard students an ability
to try out ideas, to understand
how they can have an impact on the world around them,
how can we be vibrant and integral
parts of the communities in which we are located
so that we serve them through being engaged with them
and it's not a one-way interaction but rather
a reciprocal interaction in which we understand
what we can bring to the communities in which
we're located but we also understand what those
community spring to us. We have a program
at Harvard
for service employees it's called the bridge
program. Recently I attended a celebration
of citizenship of the naturalization of thirty
three individuals who were participants in
the bridge program
and a considerable part of their preparation
for their citizenship exams
took place in conjunction with undergraduate
students who
tutored them on aspects of American history,
American government and other kinds of things
they needed to know for these exams
and wonderful relationships had grown up between
the undergraduate students
and the new American citizens and this celebration
for me marked
a marvelous achievement by a group of our
workers but also a marvelous
example of engagement by
our students. Tough economic
times make what we do all the more important
what we do in the communities that we can
help that surround us and the ways that we can
translate skills and engagement of our
students and faculty into helpful interventions
in community life
but also the ways in which our knowledge can
provide a means of service to help us understand
how to get out of these times.
It's a teaching experience, a learning experience often
and for our students and integral part of
their learning here Harvard